mario speedwagon for your third friday
after thanksgiving another red wave
warning meanwhile for the democrats
politico now reporting how quote the
democratic brand is broken and the
infrastructure bill isn't fixing it
while biden voters apparently have no
clue what the party actually stands for
and don't count on the president to bail
them out in 2022 a new poll reveals his
approval rating at an all-time low
within his own party let's go to the
democrat at the table jesse lucky me yes
what can democrats possibly do to avoid
forget wave the red tsunami that is
coming in 2022 because remember
president obama even passing obamacare
well 63 seats in 2010 donald trump lost
43 in 2018 despite the tax cuts so you
got to figure here you're looking at 60
maybe 70 seats gone so not just uh
losing the house but republicans having
a strong majority and then the senate
one seat has to flip and then you get
cocaine mitch back as your majority
cocaine match feels like he never went
away from me um
history is
a very good predictor of what's to
happen and that's why it's been so
important that democrats get through
these big pieces of legislation
you know we have bill back better if it
gets through the senate the american
rescue plan and then the bipartisan
infrastructure plan which is a win for
both sides there but democrats are
definitely nervous about this you know
three key categories of focus
independence if you look at the results
out of new jersey and virginia that's a
big problem
looking at where the hispanic vote is
going that's trending much more
conservative whereas um the asian vote
is actually drifting more democratic um
and then looking at what's going to go
on with those moderate republicans and
white college-educated men specifically
who did come over to vote for joe biden
after trump and seem to be
shifting back um i am hopeful that
people can just message on the policies
and also show the empathy and the
concern that joe biden won on in 2020
because yes coded was obviously a huge
part of that but the attitude was even
more important which was i i hear you i
see you i feel what you're feeling okay
sean as the former member of congress
here here's the thing about the
infrastructure bills where i push back
that even if these this next one does
pass it's another couple trillion
dollars into the economy you have jen
saki uh laughably saying that no
economist says that it will add to
inflation adding these trillions of
course you know plenty of economists are
saying that you take econ 101 you know
that but even if we look at the
infrastructure bill in terms of roads
and bridges and power grids right
those things will take many many years
to either upgrade or fix or add right
and once it is upgraded let's say in
other words no one's ever saying you
know my power hasn't gone out for a
while
the power grid's working pretty well or
boy that bridge didn't collapse and i
just drove over i got to thank joe biden
for that in other words i don't think
these will even have a positive impact
even when they're passed and even by the
time they're even built because people
expect their government to have these
things running well anyway well the
problem is democrats didn't reform the
way that we get approvals for these
projects so they won't happen for 10
years so people won't see the results of
them right so jessica i would agree i
would disagree with you in that it's not
the messaging of the policy it's the
policy itself that people don't like and
when you look at things that people care
about they care about the economy they
care they care about inflation you look
at borders inflation crime coven energy
that will draw from afghanistan
democrats have nothing to run on and
when you look at what joe biden focuses
on which is the weather and he's also
focusing on race those don't even hit
the list of things that people care
about things that people care about and
so if you want to get elected actually
listen to people what do you care about
what do i need to fix and the policies
are going to make inflation much worse
which is going to make the election
results in a year from now that much
harder for democrats it is amazing isn't
it again that the president within his
own party only 36 percent of democrats
want him to run again in 2024. you never
saw that with any previous presidents
before i don't think at least in my
lifetime anyway 64 of the country
overall doesn't want joe biden to run
again so my question is
who's the ticket because your plan b is
kamala harris and she's at 28 approval
so that's out i don't think andrew cuomo
is available i'm pretty sure they're not
going to put up gavin newsom so were we
looking at
democratic nominee pete bootedge
transportation secretary is doing such a
fine job with the supply chain crisis i
don't even know what i'm meeting for
dinner
so uh let's let me and i will caution so
before we get to the next presidential
election
the midterms are a long
way away
and the republicans are in the situation
they are right now
not because of anything that they've
done it's only mistakes that the
democrats have made over and over again
since they took power but between now
and next year be very careful because
the democrats are desperate they see
that window closing they will clearly
lie and they're willing to lose power in
the house and the senate
they don't care the goal is to push
through this giant welfare monstrosity
they losing power is temporary but those
programs in that bill
they're forever and that's what's
frightening that's the thing joey right
once you give somebody something for
free it's impossible to take it away we
see that with obamacare so maybe that's
the goal here
they'll take the losses if they could
get the long-term
programs in place that they know
republicans would look evil for for
taking there are things in place like
nancy pelosi's legacy probably that are
motivators but
really it is real simple the day after
this last election the word was hey
republicans are going to get the house
it's because of the map it's because
it's a census year we've redistricted
we've moved seats over we've got wesley
hunt and texas will pick up a brand new
seat there in texas and the map favors
republicans tremendously i don't think
that this is about what republicans are
going to do when the house i think it's
what democrats have done to lose it but
i don't think democrats can do anything
to win it at this point i think it will
go red especially the house and it's
really because of the technical side of
it where the map is landed it just
happens to be democrats also coughed up
a big nothing burger and a bad taste in
everyone's mouth and so now everyone are
favoring republican policies again it's
always a
referendum on the party in power no
question about it uh by the way why
can't i be joey in other words i'm still
a joe you get to be a joey it sounds
younger
it's always been joey okay very good day
one right here i'm joe koncha hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else